well welcome everybody um it's a great
pleasure to see you here today so this
is the first of two
colloquia on
novel fault tolerant
uh
quantum
architectures so today michelle deborah
we'll talk about error-corrected logical
qubits for doing i guess correcting the
coherence errors of the logical qubit i
guess is what he what he's calling it
and
and next week patrick hayden will talk
about a simple architecture
for a fault tolerant
qubit
so
um
so it's great pleasure to have michelle
here today
michelle is the professor of applied
physics at yale and the director of the
applied physics
nanofabrication lab then
um
he he did did all his
schooling in in france
um and then he did
two years
spent two years in berkeley
doing his post-doctoral work with john
clark in jordan clark's lab
[Music]
he
i guess he has a very distinguished
record and you know he um he's one of
the
one of the
um creators of this what's called what's
been called the circuit qed paradigm um
he has a number of honors which i won't
uh
you know i'll just i'll just mention the
john bell prize which he shared with uh
robert shulkoff in 2013
in the fritz london memorial prize um
2014. so uh
you know without further ado let me let
me uh
just
you know great pleasure to welcome you
here michelle and looking forward to
your talk
thank you your mesh
thank you also for the kind introduction
and
so yes today i will be talking about
indeed
a new type of architecture for error
correction
um
before i begin uh i would like uh to um
thank um the people in the personal
today danielle got test man jonathan
home shooting paulie and shannon
um i apologize in advance for the
specialist of
this field of
bosonic error correction that i will be
introducing today
so
this is uh i hope uh going to be an
introductory
doctoral talk so
um please um
um
do not pay attention to the the
simplifications um
okay
so the the experiment i am going to
discuss today has been recently
published in nature
and uh i would like to introduce the
people who have
taken the data that i will be presenting
i like
[Music]
and of course i would like to
acknowledge the help from our
interrogation colleagues
shruti pouri
stephen gervlin
yang zhang
and leon glassman and last but not least
i would like also to acknowledge uh rob
sharkop with whom i'm sharing a lab and
and with whom
it has been fun over the
last 20 years to investigate
various aspects of superconducting
circuit
so the the outline of my talk um is the
following there will be three parts so
um there's
the first two parts are very
introductory and the last part
will be devoted to the experiment that
we did and which is uh still ongoing
so um
very to start
very simply um you all know that
what we call a physical qubit is two
levels two
uh levels uh generally the first two
energy levels
of uh quantum system um we represent
the state
of the system by your point on the block
sphere
and the question that we are asking in
our experiments is can we protect the
qubit from the three arrow channels uh
labeled x y and z which we present in
this effective spin language
three orthogonal
random shields that
will
randomly shake the qubit and make it
decline
and
to analyze this question i i want to
go uh not right now in the channel
language xyz but
consider the error generators which are
bit flips and
[Music]
face flips
and to understand the principle of error
correction
let me introduce the idea of non-local
wave functions by considering a particle
there is uh sigma is
the
so the sprite the quantum spread of
the particle
due to a quantum
fluctuations
and
i suppose that i have two boxes
which are separated by a distance d
which is much larger than the extent of
these
confluctuations
and what i call a non-local wave
function is a superposition of the
particle being in the left box and the
particle being in the right box
and
this is a form of protection not a
complete protection
as you perhaps all know all these three
attacks can be decomposed into two
generators the bit flips which takes
this angle theta and adds pi
or this angle of phi and
adds
5 that's the phase flip
and of course
all these combinations will be
equivalent to these three arrow channels
so when you encode the the
qubit in this non-local way with these
two boxes which are far away
in fact in real space
i will protect um the qubit
um against uh bit flips um which would
exchange the cos and their sign and
they change the box
of course you don't protect
the qubit uh against phase flip which
correspond to different local potentials
here
and so the aim of
quantum error correction is to create an
encoding which is immune to both
the face flip and the
bit flips
and
there are two types to introduce the
kind of architecture we are interested
ikea layer i need to distinguish
two types of architecture
there is the discrete variable
architecture which is based on a
register of and physical qubit
which provides
a redundant tilde space with dimension
and equals two to the angle little end
an example well-known examples of these
are the short codes steam code surface
code color code and so on so this is a
register on
a quantum error collection
the
[Music]
architecture we are interested in the or
also called gosanic
correction
bosonic codes
involves the so-called continuous
variable approach but
i prefer to talk about the encoding of
information in an oscillator
in the discrete
flux state of an oscillator
and
as you see there's a correspondence
because
if you have
let's say little n
qubits if your register is composed of
little and physical cubits
that's uh equivalent to um
taking uh
capital and levels of the oscillator and
and taking the log in base 2.
and
this kind of code
was originally developed by uh
daniel gotesman and keep with it if and
preschool
and
more recently there are codes binomial
codes
codes and so on but but today i will
actually concentrate on this so-called
gkp encoding
in our opinion
there are
from an experimental point of view
there's a huge difference between these
two types of encoding
the register
approach
is
as the merit that
when you go to very large little anger
you the dimension of hilbert space
increases exponentially that's good but
there's a huge overhead before you can
benefit from this exponential regime
you
need essentially one josefson circuit at
least per physical tubing on the other
hand if you take the continuous viable
approach or the oscillator encoding
you have
really a much more favorable overhead
typically
only one josephson circle is needed for
oscillator but each oscillator can
encode
the equivalent of many physical cubits
to to give you an idea of the problem
with the register error correction let's
take the steen encoding
which is based on several physical qubit
and equilibrium space of 128 states so
what you do is you encode the zero
logical and the one logical in this
entangled
state
the register
and here
these
hexagons are over seven cubits
and the state is uh
these superpositions with that which
have a deep
symmetry properties i'm not going to
commend them but if you
go around the placket um in each of
these wave functions you see you will
have an even number of zeros and one in
in
both
in both wave functions
with this kind of symmetries you can in
principle correct all
errors
but
to give you an idea of the overhydra i
have actually drawn the feedback circuit
for error correction here so on the left
all these um
lines here represent the seven physical
two bits
um
and
um at the bottom here you have the six
ancillar cubits that correspond to the
detection of
six uh error syndrome
on the
three and most left columns the columns
in which you see this z
[Music]
uh parity uh measurements you uh correct
for bit flips and here you go it for big
face flips so you you by correcting uh
on the two generators you correct all
the arrows
um on the right here you have the
operation the correction operations
which depend on on what error syndromes
you decode here into the yellow box but
the problem is that you see that for one
logical qubit
you need
at least seven qubits plus uh six
ancillar cubits 13 physical qubits
for one logical cubit and even then i
have not considered the fact that the
end sellers could
have
errors also
and
all this hardware is needed to monitor
21 error channels i have seven uh qubits
here they all have
three arrow channels so
this is 21 type of errors that you have
to monitor by this circuit and correct
simultaneously so this is a quite
frightening for an experimentalist
and
this
great state encoding
that was pioneered by
a gkp in 2001
is fabulous in the sense of
limiting um the hardware to a
minimal amount actually um the fact that
this is a
so
economical in terms of hardware was not
realized until a few years ago where the
the primitive the primitive operation
that is needed
in this great state and coding was
not realized
uh very quickly uh after the this
prediction
so to introduce um how we in the lab
are going to implement this error
correction
i need to introduce
the representation of quantum states of
an oscillator in phase space
so we represent these
these quantum states like their vignette
distribution
which is
some
quasi-probability distribution
the vacuum state so p and q are the
phase space coordinate q being the
position and p being the momentum
here the units are square root of photon
numbers
and
this disk in the center correspond to
the quantum fluctuation of the vacuum
and uh if you go to the
fork ladder you will go to the one fox
state
which has this white ring of know the
distribution
then
if you have a two foot on stage you will
get two rings and so on
but
this is only
one of the few a few types of states
that you can build you can build many
other states you can build for instance
the so-called coiron state which is a
displaced vacuum
here by two units in face space
you can you can also squeeze the vacuum
um here
i have chosen the 45 orientation of the
squeezing the the fluctuations have been
reduced in along one coordinate and
increased along the other
um and
there are many other states like uh
superposition of clion states which
produce cat states and
cat states can themselves encode quantum
information and this can be very useful
but i won't be uh talking about this
during this webinar we might
we might discuss um
this question with the panel
okay so uh now having introduced
the this useful representation in face
space which
is going to be
very useful to our doctor i just want to
for a few minutes
tell you about the basic ideas um
of this
gkp code
grid state code
so the idea is that
you take the squeeze state so we we are
not
following the lead of the cat we are
following the lead of the squeeze vacuum
here
and we squeeze the vacuum along so in
order to make
essentially peak advanced wave functions
in coordinate space
and
each of these
pickets is a squeezed
state
in the coordinate
[Music]
direction and i am supposing superposing
all these sweet states
this is uh this will create zero logical
and um
it's uh it's simply a superposition of
translated vacuum three states
and
the one logical is
very
can be disused very easily from the this
zero logical it's just the same state
but translated by apartheid
um
so um with regards to my particle in
bulk schema that
fits the builder because you see
the separation in some sense between
these wave functions is maximum
um the width of each of this picket is
extremely tiny so you have a lot of
distance a relative distance between two
peakets belonging to these two states
so if you have
an error you can transfer a small
translation error you can correct it
but
what is wonderful in that code is that
you don't correct only
bit flips but also faithfully because if
i look at these wave functions in
fourier space i also
get
a pick at
a fence type of wave functions but
if i superpose these wave functions to
create the minus
and plus
state which live on the equator of the
block sphere
they also
um in some sense uh
uh maximally separated so exactly like i
can correct translations along the q
chord today i can also collect the
translation
along the p-coordinate and that corrects
both
bit flips and face-flip
and
there are also a lot of bonus in this
code so for instance the clifford
operations are and can be obtained by
combining translation and rotation so
um
there is also a marvelous property of
these codes that was
became
more clear thanks to working garvin and
jungkook which is that not only this
code can correct translations but
it can correct also photon losses
optimally and that really
is a very strong motivation because if
as oscillators you use superconducting
cavities
um then in these superconductivities
that we can make in the dominant error
mechanism is photon losses so here we we
have a code that is optimal for photon
losses in a cavity and so
[Music]
it is a very appealing code there's
one problem
uh which is uh well uh how do you create
these states
and
this is where we have to go in the in
face space again so instead of doing the
wave functions either along the queue or
the p-coordinate let's look at them in
phase space
and in face space i have to introduce
this crucial notion of
geometry of translations
so classically if i
make
a closed loop in face space if i move
let's say a representative point of the
system let's say along the u vector then
along this v vector and then i come back
and classically um i uh my system
is
returns and and is absolutely identical
quantum mechanically
the state
of the system receives a phase factor
a phase factor
which
is actually obtained by the area
divided by h power so this is a actually
a wonderful property that
actually turns out defines entirely the
difference being between classical and
quantum mechanics in
in quantum mechanics when you do a
closed circuit in face space you you um
you
suffer phase factor
that is proportional to the area
instead of writing a product of
translations in this way and
using the vector product to represent
the area
i can use complex numbers to represent
exactly the same thing and
in terms of displacement function of
complex numbers this this expression on
the right
is exactly equivalent to the expression
on the left but i can introduce here
um
the length
the modular square the length in complex
units and that's
that's a photon number
so um the gkp code uh
has two stabilizers which correspond to
two uh translations
in the
two orthogonal translations in phase
space which have a certain
amplitude in this square root of photon
number unit
and this two square root of pi is
magical in the sense that
these two translations which normally
would
not commute for arbitrary displacement
do commute
and these two stabilizers will
in that space become the identity in the
in the subspace of the code
now if you look at this area here it
does um the area formed by the
stabilizers it is uh a four pi h bar or
the equivalent of two action quantum
remember uh one state in face space is
uh one action quantum barrier so indeed
here we have um
we have an area corresponding to two
states
which
is uh
of course uh leads out to a cubit
but is is it really a
qubit in the sense of
poly operators well
if we look at these vectors
x
y and z
so the x vector
is half the vector of this
stabilizer which is equivalent to i so x
square
is indeed i this z squared
is indeed high if you think of z and x
as translation
and y of course is also um
[Music]
base the property of y square being i
because you would get here
but
now we just do a little bit of euclidean
geometry if we look at this triangle
here x
z and y it has an area of exactly
this full area divided by eight
which means that it's pi over two h bar
which corresponds to a phase factor i so
we have exactly the algebra
of the poly operators here now so this
is uh this is really wonderful and this
explains how the clifford operations
in uh will be obtained by simply
geometric
translation and rotation in phase space
okay
up to now i have considered the ideal
case where the uh the
thing is squeezing in practice we cannot
squeeze
the vacuum infinitely so
um we have to contend ourselves with the
with a state that contains a finite
number of photons so instead of an
infinite pick advance
for the
z and
the logical and
the plus and minus state
i have a finite big advance
correlatively
i the peaks are not going to be
infinitely narrow they are going to have
a certain width
given by their sigma here
the envelope the finite envelope is
controlled by delta and for the code to
be optimum
sigma and delta need to be reciprocal
with respect to
the
[Music]
unit cellular translation
so instead of that being dot uh
very space
red dots
which would be form an infinite grid in
face space
here i have
a finite number of
finite dots
but
the overlap
between two
neighboring dogs is really so small that
the food remains
absolutely excellent
and what i have plotted here along um
the um
this is this brown projections and
the state
plus and minus z
and
if you do a projection a marginal
distribution along
this side here you will get the plus and
minus x
states
now uh this
phase-based representation is very
useful to discuss
error correction
so our error correction scheme is going
to implement the equivalent of two
forces two force fields
in in phase space you have the blue
force field which corresponds to these
blue arrows
and
this force field will have to be
[Music]
they will sharpen the peak
you see the photon losses will tend to
dilute everything here and to get us
back to the ground state
and a big disc in the center
but
by applying an effective
force field that is bluefield we will
sharpen the peak
of course as we sharpen the peak
we
make the envelope larger and larger so
we need to uh
implement another force field which
corresponds to
these purple arrows on the on the
periphery which will uh constrain
the envelope so by by applying
simultaneously uh these two force fields
is two antagonistic phosphine we will
stabilize
um
a finite energy a great state actually
we will stabilize
a finite energy manifold of two of them
okay so um
that's half of the talk
now um that i have introduced the
principle of this encoding let me
now go into the experimental sector how
do we in practice uh
implement this
error correction
so this is done
by
using a superconducting cavity so
this is the block that we are using in
our experiments the main
cavity
is cylindrical
and corresponds to this red arrow at the
bottom
of this cylinder you have a post here
and you see the post in this kind of
perspective of you here
so this is
this red cavity is where the the the
logical qubit will resize it's uh it's a
iq cavity
um
it is coupled
to a low cube cavity here which
corresponds to this blue arrow
it is locu because this uh cavity is
connected to
a without an um
circuit by this long pin here so it's a
low q not because there's internal
dissipation but because this is actually
our entropy dump and this low cube
cavity is going to help us read out the
arrow syndrome in the correction
and uh this is the the the this low q
cavity and this transmission line here
will be the way um
entropy will be evacuated from the i2
cavity
and
this entropy is
essentially
[Music]
processed
by the transmog
a transmog artificial atom uh an nc like
jubilee if you want that will be
involved
in correcting this iq cavity
um there are a few numbers here that the
the the specialist of circular qed will
recognize
the the one photon in the
iq cavity leaves for about 250
microseconds
the ancillar qubit is
not
these days
is
really completely um average it's not
really the kind of best qubit that
we could make but
and there's a coupling between the
storage cavity and the nc like cubit
which is about
20
20 kilowatts and and then uh this is uh
the characteristic of the
low q cavity and we can basically read
out
the information in
in one microsecond
out of this uh
cavity one one very important
factor here is the
is the feedback time constant
we we um we can feedback so when we read
the cavity and we can feedback
what we
information we get and the correct
the this iq cavity in a time constant
which is about 300 nanoseconds so
a fraction even of the time it takes to
without this transmit this is absolutely
crucial because as i have explained
quantum mechanics
based on
the possibility of doing this feedback
um to explain how we monitor errors and
even how we we create the state in the
first place i have to explain the
fundamental operation the fundamental
gate that
made this error correction
the
gkp code possible it's this
conditional displacement gate and
without this kind of gate
we could not really create this
stage so there's um this is why uh this
gate i call the the swiss army knife of
this encoding because uh with this gate
you can do absolutely everything you can
create those states you can stabilize
them you can read them out you do all
we are
going to spend a little bit of time
explaining how it
works so in the doubly rotating frame of
both the ancillar qubit and the gkp node
the handling is just
this
so the nc like qubit is considered as a
spin here hence the sigma z
and here this is the hamiltonian
we couple the photon number of the
cavity to the sigma z of the cubic and
then we dried the cavity
this drive produces
a lot of terms a lot of unwanted terms
that we are going to eliminate by echo
methods
but there's one surviving term um which
couples
the
a and a dagger to actually
the field that we create in the cavity
with the drive and which is represented
by this um
[Music]
term here
which is the the coherent state mp2 that
we create in the cavity without running
so uh here is how this displacement gate
function so suppose that
i want to take a state in the cavity and
here i have taken a squeeze state as as
an example but i could have taken
any
in any state
so real alpha and imagine the position
and the momentum in this cavity
and i'm going to displace this state
depending on whether the cubit is in e
and g
so
we begin by uh driving the cavity and
displaying displacing the state and this
coupling here is going to um
displace
and work with the
on whether the qubit is in energy
and you see we want to get rid of the
rotation so through this clever echo
sequence we can actually
get a clean displacement at the end of
this sequence
and
this is really the the key to this
conditional displacement gate a sort of
mulling out of all the unwanted terms
that is generated by the tribe
and with this gate we can
build superposition of squeezed
states in the cavity but we can also
using the gate in reverse i detect a
small displacement so
that you have made
a superposition of the squeeze state and
now
due to some kind of translation error
here
this wave function that you created is
displaced by a small amount epsilon
so
uh with this circuit with
using this conditional gate between
two pi over two pulses here
and weeding out the ancillar qubit at
the end you're going to be able to
detect
this small displacement or more
precisely you're going to
actually transform this displacement you
see you you have
a sort of interference effect which
makes all the the influence of all these
peak converge
and we rotate the qubit in the
equatorial plane by an angle with a
vector which is proportional to this
displacement and then reading out the
ancillary we get one bit of information
on this displacement we get for instance
the sign of this displacement and just
with this sign we can actually
actually
by repeating this measurement over and
over we can actually reposition
the
the
state in the in face space in the right
place
of course
in order to be able to do that you have
to calibrate this conditional
displacement this cd gate very precisely
and
this is done by doing
basically
two opposite rotations in phase space
depending on the state of the qubit and
the interference between these two
cycles create
a very phased oscillation which we use
actually to calibrate the gate once
we've done this calibration
we can actually
create use this protocol where
we can
we can
actually
do
four type of feedback loops
that are intertwined
and they sharpen the peak along the q
direction they trim the envelope
on the q direction and here we have a
mirror sequence which does the same
thing but in the key direction and we
repeat this cycle over and over
and
there's a parameter um
which is
this amount of displacement we do in the
feedback loop which is optimized by the
which were optimized by uh simulation
when we did the experiment but now we
here we
allows us to to understand exactly how
to compute this optimal epsilon
and
so here
this result shows the
the average value of the stabilizers
that
really increase and
attain a plateau and you see that you
see this period form
here in these oscillations toward the
ascent
but that corresponds to the fact that in
order to do a full round of correction
we need to apply these four operations
in sequence and after a few hundred
rounds of error correction you find the
the mixed logical state
um so it's a random superposition of the
two logical states in
including space
and here
i have um i have
really given the unique cell line of
of the grid
and indicated
where the the the position of the x
y and z operator so here we have a mixed
logical state we have not prepared a
straight copper but if we measure
um
at this point here and by the way i
should say that
this is actually a characteristic
function but
it's the fourier transform of the finger
distribution that i
presented before
and
if you have
agreed
in direct space you have also agreed in
reciprocal
space
so this characteristic function contains
exactly the same kind of information we
would find in the wigner function so
when uh when we measure at this location
x y and z we will get we will project
the
the state on the on the niger
function of the x y and z operator and
this is uh what we do here in this
experiment so
this is um
the prepared manifold stabilize manifold
and by
doing a measurement here on this point
you see for instance we we find a
negative value which means that we have
prepared actually a minus x logic one
and um
we can repeat the same operation and
create
x states y states and even by
teleportation from the ancillar cubit we
can create even the magic state
and um this is all done in this
original square code that i presented
but there is an interesting variation in
this grid state code you can implement
what is called the hexagonal code in
which the direction along x y and z are
actually isotropic
instead of having
two
equivalent direction x and z
and having
the diagonal along while here
the x y and z
directions um
make an angle
of
120 degrees so this is why for instance
the x state
and the y state in this encoding
are just essentially the same state but
rotate it by 120 degrees
uh here i show the difference between
the unit cell in the square code
and
in the hexagonal code and you can see
that now
the the three operators
corresponding to x
y and z
basically have the same length
there's a there's a
a certain superiority of the hexagonal
encoding so these results really are the
punchline of the talk
they represent uh
by how much you can collect errors and
we measure the correction arrivals by uh
preparing a certain state
which can be along x y and z
and then we measure measure sometime
later the same operators x y and z
um in the free decay mode where we do
not do any correction and these are the
white dots here
and um the um
as you can see uh with correction
this is what we call stabilized here
um you can see a a
nice separation of the um
x and z uh operator measurement
um
which basically we
essentially
doubled
the lifetime of these operators we also
doubled the lifetime of the y operator
but you see we start with the
sevia handicap
and if we go to the hexagonal code
all three operators behave exactly in
the same way because of this rotational
symmetry
okay so
um i think that
i have reached
the
time i would like to leave some time for
questions and final discussion
there's
some important point that i want to
talk about
and
this was
really realized um
in jonathan home group recently
uh this is the question rob famous
what i have presented
now
is
feedback
measurement feedback
error collection but this code
has this wonderful peculiarity which was
discovered independently
jonathan holmes group and in uh steven
uh
group that actually
you can
concatenate
the operations that i have
mentioned these feedback operations here
in the in the protocol that
i have presented
and eliminate completely the need for
measurement feedback all you need is to
reset periodically the ancilla more
precisely you can contact the container
and operations which sharpens the in q
and the trimming in p
and
resetting the insula as exactly the same
effect as going out of the quiesca and
actually applying the correction so this
is a an incredible
incredible advantage of this code not
only you can correct all errors
and
all the possible errors
of the money folder
but you can do it uh autonomously which
if you think of uh
many many logical qubits saves saves a
lot of wider sound
and
on this note i would like to
show my conclusion slider
so
i think that
this gkp code has
allowed us to simultaneously correct all
errors so it's not just that we correct
one or two errors among all the errors
uh we correct all arrows all of of
course all arrows are converted to first
order so we don't have a cubit that
lives forever we have a qubit that lives
longer
and
we
longer than if we don't do uh error
correction that is
there's this question of break even
very even point which is whether we can
with this code
do even better than the best encoding in
the cavity so right now we of course do
better than uh without error correction
keeping the encoding the same but the
question of breakeven is the following
so can you beat with your error
correction scheme which
is
always going to be more complicated than
the simplest physical qubit can you can
you beat
the
the lifetime the coins lifetime of the
simplest non-correctable encoding and
the answer is uh up to now almost so we
we have new results in the lab
which which indicate that we are very
close to to do it but
i think this is ongoing progress
but it will be nice to to have all um
errors corrected and
and go beyond the breakeven point this
this has never been achieved
um
very
very interesting this direction is of
course the two the gates between two
logicals and for instance the synod gate
is particularly appealing with gkp
because it's a
simple gaussian operation which actually
we know how to do in the real number of
amplifiers so we we have already built
josephson junction circuits that do this
with
this protocol but of course we have to
apply
apply this this protocol and hardware to
the gkp and kodi
and
and then there is this
fabulous direction of
error correction feedback which
we're also
doing um right now so this this is going
to help tremendously
uh actually because
the
break event
and um
i don't want to to steal the the
thunder the final discussion but uh
maybe um a very important point here is
that um
the in my opinion the
the great advantage
as an experimentalist of the boson
recruiter
is that they constitute
really
extremely hardware efficient so it was
de-missing here
and
a first layer of
error correction if you think of a stack
of error correction layers
[Music]
this is this is a great layer because it
doesn't
require much overhead so um there's
there are articles and i hear i'm
quoting the article of
shruti
um
on the
advantage of this
efficient
first layer
made of gkp encoding
probably on the
on the upper layers you will need
something that resembling the uh the
surface code or the color code
but um
to be able to in the first stage to
arrive at the at the level of
a very
small error rate and high fidelity with
the
the minimal handler is
very very important because if
you wait the first player you need
something like 52 bits per logic of
2-bit
that is a tremendous barrier a
tremendous
experimental barrier to
implement
multi-layer
quantum error collection
so
on this note i'll
i'd like to thank you for your attention
and
and
i think we can start
the discussion
great uh thank you michelle that was a
there was a very thought-provoking talk
um
so let's uh let's see if there any
questions
[Music]
so while while people are um you know
please
post in qa or chat if you have a
question but uh
okay so i see that there's a there's a a
question in in q and a
by two
he says you briefly showed the creation
of a magic state
but can you say more about how you can
perform non-clifford gates on this
platform to complete a universal gate
set
yes
i think um
answer this question better than i am
we'll be able to do but but uh yes so um
this magical state
that we created was
done
by teleporting
stating the ancilla and mapping it into
the oscillator so that that doesn't
belong to the kind of
operation that could be done
[Music]
but there are ways to actually
create the magical state
which
would be better than in the surface code
and
and
inside the inside the bosonic codes
there are opportunities for
creating magic states and magic state
distillation
that
is
more efficient than
with the traditional register encoding
maybe shorty you would want to to answer
this
possibly we can get to it in the once we
start the panel but actually before we
start the panel can i ask a very uh
basic question because i think that this
may be on people's minds so so right now
you were you were saying how to how to
encode a qubit in this
in the in this uh
um
uh in the in the
microwave uh
um you know in in this in this cavity
mode so um
in the excitations in the cavity and
and
uh but but um
is is is
what is the architecture that you would
you would be thinking of you know when
you when you're storing multiple qubits
you know is there trade-off you know in
terms of how accessible the qubits are
and how much you can operate on them or
get them to talk to each other so
what what how exactly do you do you
think about organizing this architecture
and what
how do you get there
get
uh interact
so um
so let me let me first
say that
jonathan home is
is implementing
this kind of error correction with
trapped ions
at uth and i'm sure he will have
a lot to comment on in the panel
discussion i think
the this question of architecture will
uh when you think about
multiple
uh multiple logical cubits will play out
quite differently um
in the agon and the super conducting
circuit community so i i don't want to
speak uh too much in general
but
i can i can
give you some indication of the way it
would be done with the superconducting
tubing so with superconducting qubits
in this 3d architecture that i have
presented
what you do what you create is
an array uh
either 2d or 3d array
a partly 3d array of cavities and this
has been shown for instance that
this possibility has been shown by david
schuster at chicago
um
and
this
in in this kind of architecture you have
sufficient room i would say between the
cavities to
for the access control wires
of the ancillary
without so that's not
in my mind there's not right now
implementing let's say a hundred
cavities um
[Music]
let's say 10 by 10 array of what type of
cavities i have shown now is
would be rather straightforward what
what is difficult is to
to assemble
all the control lines and all the
control electronics
necessary to service all these signals
this is really
right now i think for the groups that um
deal with these cavities the the the
butt that is the most daunting the the
machining of
the the
the cavity itself
the the
arrays of cavities are not
i'm not too much of problem it's but in
terms of controlling and
multiplicity of signals that have to
that have to reach all the cavities i
think is is a is the challenge for
academic groups
great
well thanks thanks very much this is a
pretty fascinating subject so uh we we
have a very distinguished panel who
you know who represent expertise from
various points of view on this on this
subject so